Vì một cầu học sinh ra việc nè, nèm lấp mới,
vấy số khọt mỏng tới cá đồng mỏng
ở chợ trình thó học sinh của một trường trước học và Mỹ.
Từ một lâu vàng 2,5 trở người tiếp xúc 2 năm,
tới người nhận tích tháng buổi một không trước lớt hủ sình só khách.
Mò người có thể hiểu được.
2 năm choi mà thu ba người hay nhận.
Lớ nhục như thế nào?
Cái trình tháng đầu tiên.
Anh may hợp.
Nhìn tháng tháng thứ 2,
và lúc tích thật này đó là cái mình đã tập rồi.
Ok, không phải mạnh hơn.
Thì thì mình là đó không biết là hợp.
Rớt và hợp trở lại mà mình mang tối gạo lúc.
Từ vì chỉ đau tư ở quyền màu hiểm,
ở vài trò vẫn hành bột sát đáp AI
gọi được môi tám phê nè chứ đối lòng ý.
Hành trình cốm nguyễn hành hệm giám đốc vẫn hành của AI hay.
Lúc là những cuộc chiếc lúc hẹn.
Thì vì trọng có nừng an thoàn ở chợ tập tại chính.
Anh hề quái về vện đặc nếu cố vết người chiếc,
chấp nhận giảm thung nhạm còn phần tư,
để cung đồng lỗi xe dựng một sản phẩm AI hương về.
Với tình thần của biết ở câu hôm,
anh bu vào mấy năm phải,
nơi bỏ cuộc gặp với nhà đầu tư,
khu cọng là một lịch hình,
mà là sức mạnh của cuộc tư.
Đấy này phải trở lất là lắm rồi.
Mà đã invest vào những câu tư có thể gọi là đại nói,
đại nói của chúng cũng lúc mần đi vào qua không lắm mặt lần.
Bắt chơi, lỗi lạm.
Mà sống, môi trởi đưa.
Trời ơi,
thì mình cứ nói,
mình sẽ cũng mặt nóng rồi.
Sau khi bỗng lần,
có có phương mạnh,
và cả sau càng phực cướng.
Đấy,
hẹp bà đời gũ và kíu mọng thẳng phọng lớn,
đứa cấp nhà lọi AI của gửi vi.
Bà đời sống của một tắp chếu gửi vi.
Với hiệp,
sang vật,
phòng họp nhà đầu tư,
anh thì trởi AI đều trụ nhau.
Bộ tư khi nào mà đứa tìm thị đau,
mình phải chóng người của người của người của người của người của người.
Để sẽ xong đánh.
Đà 1st step,
là nơi cái câu sẽ chói chuyện với những người,
giở phần,
là nghe lý cho họ khởi tạo,
và cách bọn rừng.